we both I mean we've literally become
best friends throughout our
relationships Lydia Hearst is gushing
over married life with Chris Hardwick
exclusively to ET two months after
saying I do what's the biggest change
that you've seen since you guys have
gotten married uh well we get to spend
more time together because now we're
living together so that's a plus you
guys don't live together before you know
what's the biggest challenge um
maybe cooking dinner every night and
remembering to clean up after sometimes
you just really don't want to clean the
dishes after you've like prepared meal
yeah the whole thing well I don't want
to jump too far ahead but are you guys
talking kids at all yeah we are but we
want to sort of be together and
celebrate our relationship and at least
have one year before we start trying
make in a year we'll start playing with
the ideas I think to Mike Pierre limit
but who knows I mean that's what my
sister said and she's about to have her
third how did you know that he was the
one we went away on a trip together and
we were on a ranch and I know it sounds
bizarre he was playing with all these
cattle dogs and puppies and he literally
took off into the field running after
the cows and it was that instant moment
I was like oh my gosh I I have to spend
the rest of my life with this man it's
hard to make relationships last in
Hollywood so for you guys what's the
trick do you have rules or anything no I
mean I think you just have to be honest
and happy and communicate you have to be
a sounding board and I think you should
both have the common goal of wanting to
make each other happy and we do and I
feel very fortunate 32 year old newlywed
is keeping busy
she's the ambassador for this year's
scream fest what's your guys's favorite
scary movie to watch together
uh you know we watch pretty much
anything and everything all things were
I mean obviously we watch a lot of
Walking Dead because that's his job and
it's amazing we just we love [ __ ] an
incredible genre
you